[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you all for joining us for the
second annual tribeca games spotlight
the several of tribeca selections this
year are second acts as well sequels
that return to worlds or characters that
we love and fresh perspectives and new
adventures some tell stories about
family cultural identity and coming of
age as a child a teen or an adult facing
a world that never stops changing they
invite us to investigate mysteries and
navigate familiar
yet dangerous terrain or simply just
cook a meal with people we love
others explore our fears about the
future through dystopian tales of
environmental ruin or technology run
amok but all of them offer us an
opportunity to think
play and challenge ourselves
whether that means a much needed break
from the worries of our daily lives or
an experience that tells us something
true
about what it means to be alive
whatever you're looking for chances are
you're gonna find a little bit of it in
these games
here are the 2022
tribeca game selection
[Music]
it isn't always easy going back to the
place where you grew up
for jala the star of thirsty suitors
going back home for her sister's wedding
means that she's gonna be facing
unresolved issues with her family her
friends and a string of angry exes
as jala you're going to be forced to
confront everything that you have been
avoiding through cooking challenges and
colorful turn-based battles where you're
going to be face-to-face with the
biggest adversary of all
the decisions you made in the past
hope your bag is packed it's time for a
trip back home with thirsty suitors
outer loop games is a fully remote
studio that we started five years ago
but the idea of making games about
underrepresented cultures and themes the
studio is about 15 folks and we're
scattered from seattle washington to
vancouver to the uk toronto east coast
of u.s like new york and then two in
brisbane our first project was game
called falcon age it's an action
adventure game about raising a falcon
and fighting colonizers falcon age was
the first time
i personally have ever worked closely
with someone else who's brown and south
asian on a team i've been in the
industry for about eight years by that
point so
that's actually pretty shocking when you
think about it and i think one of the
great things about that for me was the
kind of conversations you can have the
kind of work that you can do and you're
coming from a similar basis and a
similar background and experience that's
why i was really excited about working
on thirsty suitors
hey y'all
you've been reckless with other people's
hearts for so long jala it was a matter
of time before you erect your own
morning ma
thirsty suitors is an action-adventure
rpg about immigrant culture resolving
relationships family pressure and
finding oneself
timber hills
our hometown i still don't get why we're
back here jala is an extremely relatable
character for anyone who's really had
that moment of moving away from home and
then coming back
she
sometimes isn't quite aware of the
things that she's doing in terms of like
hurting people
maybe i should just call tyler and get
it over with i mean yes tyler's your ex
bestie but she's also your ex
the ex
she's kind of a hot mess at the
beginning of the game and that sets up
an interesting dynamic for the player to
get to know each of her exes
because your third grade boyfriend just
walked in the door
every time you battle one of your exes
they go into their own inner space like
a fantasy land you look surprised to see
me jala
or are you just admiring the view
so the way we design combat is based on
like a non-violent beating up with each
other what i consciously did was not to
have any punches that connect all the
props are being used as thrown objects
or
punches and kicks exist but they only
exist in the form of like a holographic
fizz that comes out
come on sergio
let's dance
did i mention i spent a year abroad i
learned a lot of new moves
trying to distract me with your chest
hair is definitely cheating when we
started thinking about the visible
inspiration it was about coming up with
a style that matched the
lightheartedness
and the theme of the game i wanted to
create artwork that felt light that felt
bold graphic
with vivid colors
i love you jala i have loved you since
our hands met reaching for the same tub
of lime green play-doh in third grade
love me this is the longest conversation
we've had in over a decade
i enjoyed the fact that this game is
about reconciliation because that's
something that a lot of people don't get
to do in real life
i'm sorry i came on so strong
i've had this fantasy of you in my head
for so long
it's time i got to know the real you i'm
ready to move on if you are i'm glad we
figured that out in a lot of families
food plays a large role in the culture
and a large role in learning things from
your parents and being able to pass
those on and it's a part of jala's
journey
being able to reconcile that
relationship with her parents it's an
outlet for her to be able to do that on
their grounds and you know reconnect
with her culture
the skating session in our game is
supposed to be really easy and
accessible because i didn't want to make
like this hardcore skate simulator so
the way i've designed the game is to
make the players be able to do fun
looking things like wall run grinds and
other acrobatic tricks on a skateboard
without the complexity of button inputs
from where we're coming from we're
making this game we want it to feel very
familiar to immigrants and
people of color and particularly like
south asians so that they can see
themselves but i think it's also a very
enjoyable act of like speculation and
fantasy for anyone else you know come be
part of this we're making a role-playing
game part of the pleasure of that is in
inhabiting someone else
and living their life and i think that's
kind of what we want to give players
this idea of being very grounded in jala
this very specific character and her
story and her personality some of which
are shaped by her culture and some of
which is who she is
[Music]
imagine a world where the richest people
on the planet move to mars in the midst
of a climate catastrophe in the cub
that's the question facing a child who
has found a way to survive in the ruins
of a mutated earth
but when the ultra rich return on an
expedition
they may get a lot more than what they
bargained for
[Music]
demagogue studio is a group of
filmmakers writers architects musicians
animators and developers who make
interactive experiences for a generation
that might just live to witness the end
times
we started experimenting with a couple
of satirical games that led to golf club
wasteland
our first commercial success
currently we demagogues are working on
two games
one of which is a prequel and sequel to
golf club wasteland
a 2d cinematic platformer called the cub
[Music]
the cub is essentially the jungle book
set in an urban silicon valley-like
apocalypse
[Music]
after the great climate catastrophe
the ultra rich have evacuated to tesla
city on mars
the rest of us died
[Music]
years later
when a research mission revisits earth
they spot a human-like mutant kid while
playing golf
upon discovering the cub the science
expedition turns into a relentless
safari-like hunt the kid ducks and dives
through urban ruins the little barbarian
bastard has a plan
[Music]
while traversing this vibrant
post-apocalyptic world the cub wears a
space helmet he scavenged from a dead
martian
the helmet is radio nostalgia from mars
a radio station based on mars streaming
music and stories of tesla city
dweller's memories of their former home
earth
the radio callers are nostalgic for our
today
this is future archaeology
future retro
a sci-fi scenario that prompts us to
re-evaluate the things we already have
today from friends and family to basic
things like air and water as marshall
mcluhan would say we march backwards
into the future
similarly the brutalist architecture in
the environment serves many non-obvious
functions
brutalism stands for the 20th century
and its apocalyptic war history it
stands for faith in large-scale progress
through technology that spans multiple
ideologies which led to breakthroughs
but also to pollution and climate change
in the 21st century we have a brutalism
of the soul a reordering of the human
psyche through the internet as
exemplified in the millennial pink neons
peppered throughout our game cityscapes
such as digidopamine
or doomscrolling
modernist architecture looks powerful
yet it's already turning into ruins just
as humanity might
the sun
the game is an homage to cinematic
platformers such as heart of darkness
but also old-school sega games like the
jungle book or aladdin
[Music]
further inspiration is drawn from
classic literature cinema and popular
culture
a reflection on our commitment to
storytelling and world building
the game has numerous interactive
objects to find that enrich and inform
the narrative and also poke fun at
future and current events at the same
time
[Music]
hopefully the game will make people feel
open the players minds and thereby bring
a change in global politics and a
universal bliss for all humanity
you know what platformers are best at
enlightenment of the soul
[Music]
in 1998 the fates of two families
converge at a motel in the arizona
desert where a robbery gone wrong
changes all of their lives forever
as the tale unfolds over the next few
decades step into the shoes of multiple
characters to decide how that night will
alter the course of their lives through
a unique art style featuring actors
digitally integrated into a beautiful
cinematic world
this is as dusk falls
hello i'm caroline and i'm charu we're
excited to be here and we'd love to tell
you more about interior night and our
game as dusk falls
oh hey there got your car towed back for
you you were right it's more than i can
fix with duct tape and a socket wrench
what do i owe you nothing
your guests get around back
what in the world
on the ground now
i said get on the ground
as those fools is an interactive story
the decisions you make do have
consequences
our story is a crime drama that explores
the intertwined lives of two families
over 30 years
we have the loving family the walkers so
what's next license plate game another
round of row row your boat
and the holes
which are the more desperate family
come on
this is two rock not nypd blue
now get looking for that safe as you
play the game you will be stepping in
the shoes of different characters
first vince the dad who is rooting his
family to missouri you are my flock and
i plan to herd you to st louis in high
spirits
and on their way in arizona they get
caught in a hostage situation
[Applause]
there's also jay who is one of the
members of the other family the hostage
takers so you get to see understand the
world from his perspective jay
what head out of the clouds little bro
look
there's enough cash in that safe to put
the last few weeks behind us we stay
alive we keep the house everything goes
back to normal
there's our third main character who is
zooey
daddy are we gonna play you bet we're
gonna play who you see across the six
chapters from when she's six until she's
19 and she's becoming this young woman
the visual art style of our game is
unique and it was crafted especially to
tell this compelling story it mixes
beautifully painted 2d characters and
sets them in an evocative 3d world
we film genuine and nuanced performances
from actors to capture complex emotions
and facial expressions players don't
look at pixels they watch people in all
their humanity
[Music]
when it comes about like writing the
story we work probably a bit more like
tv
it's a very long process it's dozens of
versions of script so it's not a linear
one version of the story we have to
think all the choices all the narrative
space all the branches feeding into one
another it's kind of a 3d map
[Music]
how could you have thought you'd be
happier without your family
i mean without mine i'd i'd be i don't
know
i guess i just never liked being tied
down
with a family i
felt
trapped
we rule every character from a place of
empathy and we try not to be judgmental
towards any of them we try to understand
each of them and i hope the players will
feel the same way and try to empathize
and understand and relate with all of
them
did you get the money oh we got it all
right
nice work guys hold on tight
[Music]
family meals are a time not just to
create memories but to share them for
wenber the mother of the family cooking
is a way to connect to the culture and
the life that she has left behind and
pass those memories on to a young son
each recipe she teaches him is not just
a list of ingredients but a piece of a
much larger story about where he comes
from who his family is and the
challenges they face here's a taste of
what's to come in wemba
how did you get started in game
development
well basically i took a quiz online to
figure out what my career should be back
when i was in high school and after i
did the quiz it said i should be a video
game developer
[Music]
we were working on this project called
balloon man it was this mega man style
boss rush game about this depressed
superhero whose super powers are only to
make balloons we were a couple of months
into the project when abby texted me
this paragraph pitch of venva i was i
remember the day i was eating at a
restaurant with my mom and my sister
[Music]
bender is a narrative cooking game where
you play as manpad who moves to canada
in the late 1980s uh but during this
move her respectful gets damaged so as
the player not only will he be cooking
various southern dishes to restore these
recipes but he will also be exploring
the story of this family and the unique
challenges that they face and the idea
resonated with me so much um maybe
because my mom was there i felt a
connection to the idea because it's
about a mother and a son it was too
compelling to
not work on so we decided to move on to
venba vimba at its core is about the
relationship between the mother and the
son one aspect that we wanted to touch
upon was the loss of language as kevin
grows up here and grows more assimilated
he loses touch with his mother and
thumber and he adopts
english instead so as a result the
literal communication between wenba and
kevin is quite broken and you can see
this in the recipe book given to benba
by her mother as well because in the
travel the words and the pages get
damaged so as a result the communication
between generations there too is quite
broken
binba who feels a lot of guilt for
having moved to canada in the first
place doubles down on the things she
holds a theater like her culture her
language or food the longer she stays
here so it becomes really important for
her to fix the recipe book
because for her that's a way for this
link to persist across generations
[Music]
in our household we very rarely ate
outside food so cooking was very
important everything was made from
scratch and daily
and unlike bamba there were no recipes
food was just made by testing taste
improvising and masking around
cooking gameplay specifically was a big
challenge for us
[Music]
most cooking games that we know take a
lot of the physical elements of cooking
like chopping an onion or flipping a pan
and turn those into actual gameplay
mechanics this didn't really fit the
theme in the story of venba and that's
where the damage recipe book idea came
to fruition
[Music]
we thought that a puzzle-based cooking
game made for a much more compelling and
appropriate gameplay mechanic
[Music]
i wanted the sound effects to be really
realistic and reminiscent of a south
asian kitchen i recorded like the dish
word that we use and utensils just items
from the kitchen
but that also involves a lot of
recording of actual cooking
i wanted the sounds to be very nostalgic
for those that grew up in a similar
background
i wanted this emotional impact to come
across through sound
the music in this game it primarily
comes from an in-game radio influenced
by summer movies and music that were a
huge part
of my life growing up and we took a lot
of effort to make sure that the songs
sound like something you would hear back
home when you turn the radio on
[Music]
it was the hardest thing for me to
choose what recipes get showcased in the
game it's impossible to do justice to
the wide range of dishes and
cuisines that we have instead i just
focused on what recipes would make for
fun gameplay puzzles and what
ingredients would this family have
living in toronto even though the story
of emba is pretty firmly rooted in tamil
culture we think it hits on some pretty
universal themes
[Music]
the influences for this game it
primarily draws from the stories of the
families that i see here especially the
relationship between first generation
parents and their children
[Music]
we're hoping that in the future we'll
keep being able to tell these kinds of
intimate stories through gameplay
you know maybe you'll it'll make you
want to call your mother in the end
two years ago the game of plague tale
innocence invited audiences into the
world of omesia a teenage girl living in
14th century france
as a miser you had to use courage in
cunning to protect your five-year-old
brother hugo from soldiers of the french
inquisition swarms of rats carrying the
black plague and the supernatural evil
coursing through hugo's veins
now emisia and hugo are back in a new
adventure called a plague tale requiem
get ready for hand-to-hand battles and
ruin castles thrilling adventures on the
high seas
and yes
more rats than ever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is it
the bite yes
they think the arena down they let them
die here
[Music]
foreign
i don't know what's happening to me
lucas
i i feel my mind going
is
um
it's bleeding again
yes we should fix that before it gets
infected
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you should sit down
oh so that's all you have to say
on
you can do better than that you have a
whole garrison here why don't you really
let yourself go stop no
do you see the situation we're in
we were just supposed to get hurt
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know what's happening to me
lucas
[Music]
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Music]
would his majesty allow us to enter the
city by his side
i allow
[Music]
when cuphead came out in 2017 the first
thing people noticed was
the distinctive cartoon art style
inspired by the golden age of american
animation where every frame was drawn by
hand now cuphead is back with a new
adventure called delicious last chorus
with a whole bunch of new enemies and
ways to die and a new heroine named ms
chalice so
if you are up for the challenge get
ready for cuphead delicious last course
so
[Music]
after the first game released
we had that itch to go back and revive
some of the material that landed on the
cutting room floor well looks like it's
bound voyage to our old pals cuphead bug
man and the lovely miss chalice
they're off on their next adventure this
time to the table dlc island the
delicious last course is more
fantastical cartoon action it's a true
second helping of screen filling boss
battles imaginative stages and new
powers
this new adventure and expansion lets us
really give miss chalice a chance to
shine
[Music]
we had always envisioned her playing a
really important role as part of the
main trio of heroes
this was our opportunity to further
explore animation music
gameplay homages all of which we didn't
get to in the first game
[Music]
the origin of the original cuphead
character
we probably went through about 300
concepts
we began brainstorming in the 1930s
tradition of giving inanimate objects
faces and personalities
we really wanted to create essential
character that could sit alongside some
of the iconic joyful heroes we loved
growing up like felix the cat and mickey
and bimbo
and then one day we just had one of
those
amazing aha moments when a loose sketch
of a silhouette of a cup and a straw
began to take form that would eventually
become
cuphead
[Music]
[Music]
having the chance to re-explore this
world to make something special for our
fans
while taking our time
on the little details and making sure
we're getting them just right in so many
ways cuphead
game and character has been with our
whole team through life's many changes
these characters have become like
children of sorts
and getting a chance to take them on a
new adventure to close this chapter of
their story is just really exciting
well there's a new challenge waiting
around every corner on the amazing dlc
island
[Music]
[Applause]
2016's oxenfree introduced the
supernatural coming-of-age story of a
teenage girl named alex and her friends
celebrating the end of a school year on
the mysterious edwards island
contemplating their futures and
accidentally opening a ghostly rift
two lost signals brings us a different
kind of coming-of-age story one about
riley in her 30s facing the choices she
made as a young adult and figuring out
what comes next
this is oxen free 2 lost signals
welcome welcome first we're going to
have a little fun tonight folks
residents reported strange interruptions
in their radio broadcast
ah
bit of a leap there oh we could climb
down here also it might take a little
longer i just don't think we can make
the gap i can make it probably
can you
because
well uh we'll see won't we
riley
riley
what i think has allowed oxenfree to
have such a long life in the hearts of
our players are these characters it's
all about the characters the characters
of oxenfree are intended to feel like
people that you would know you're
invested in their well-being the issues
that they deal with are ones that
everybody can relate to what does it
mean to lose somebody that you love what
does it mean to be entering a new moment
of your life that you're totally
unprepared for it's open-ended enough
that you can always ask yourself what
would i do in this situation
watch your step i don't think this was
meant for tourists
it's
sort of pretty in a way
no it's amazing in another life it would
have been a geologist
or took at least an intro to geology
course you know
oxenfree is a game about some really
relatable characters but put in crazy
unrelatable situations riley's from
kamina and unlike alex and her friends
in oxford 3-1 riley did not have the
best time growing up in this area the
first game really tight kind of focus on
a few classmates this game is about
riley coming home and interacting with
jacob who is somebody who she went to
high school with dealing with her father
dealing with a whole host of new
characters that are along this coast
if you know the tunnel is well enough
you can walk to and from practically any
point in town completely underground
have you
been down here before
me uh
personally
no
some of the kids do or did in high
school they crawl in here light a fire
make out or whatever
but i'm too little a fan of small dark
spaces to really see the desire i'm
really looking forward to people playing
with jacob who is their kind of main
counterpart throughout the game take a
look at jacob he's got this questionable
facial hair he's got the hipster hat
funny huh just a little light makes
everything both less and more spooky
weird right
and his animation also gave him that
laid back kind of hey i'm just hanging
out here in the woods not being creepy
jacob actually has direct ties to the
events of oxford one and particularly
the history of maggie adler maggie was
the woman that first kind of discovered
what radios could do she was the one who
was kind of tied to the events that
really kicked off the whole story
if you're on this frequency
yes
my mom used to tell me
because one of the stories was about
tonight and the things that are going on
the cool thing about the radio is that
it opens up a whole different axis of
exploration to the player it's not just
exploring edwards island as a space it's
exploring edwards island as an infinite
number of kind of radio frequencies
certain objects in the game will
resonate with certain frequencies
[Music]
[Music]
hey it worked i think
i mean
we're not dead the alternate timelines
in the oxford universe are really
interesting because
it allows the player to explore the
possibility of going back and changing
the past i think we're back when the
mine was somewhat operational i don't
think anyone's around
let's uh see if the time tear opened
anything up the player gets to open
these portals in time and go through
them and talk to these other ghostly
characters portals are getting open when
they don't want it to happen and so
they've got to deal with the
ramifications of that portals are
fascinating very beautiful very
mysterious
but ultimately very dangerous
[Applause]
jacob
the stakes are very high for this one
one we've got a new set of antagonists
who are uh actually actively trying to
open a portal on their own for some
nefarious reasons but two while that is
happening we're seeing tears in time
those tears are allowing things from
completely other timelines to start
coming in and out of our timeline it's
going to be much less about some
localized little thing in this town and
it's more about the fabric of time and
space kind of melting down
i mean look when you're messing the time
space continuum that's just a bad idea
[Music]
[Music]
in immortality created by sam barlow
full transparency i'm a huge fan of his
previous games her story and telling
lies you don't just find one you find
three unreleased films spanning over
three decades and they all star
marissa marcel who has since
disappeared so can you
watch footage and behind the scenes
clips and interviews to piece together
the mystery of
marissa marcel
this
is immortality
what is your name marissa marcel
first heard about marissa marcel in
2015. i was at a party in hollywood and
i was listening into these old guys um
writers producers who were big in the
70s they were swapping war stories
gossiping and one of them brings up the
story of marisa
this actress who shoots three movies
over three decades
and how none of the movies ever comes
out
i was interested and after the party i
went home and i googled and found very
little of anything online
but i was intrigued so i continued to
dig and attempted to find something more
concrete
now we know you're from the movie that
you just finished shooting it is
finished right yeah it's finished yeah
if you don't know it's a bit of a fairy
tale so arthur fisher the great director
who uh you probably know from his movies
such as marion and the man who dreamed
was casting for his new movie ambrosio
and so instead of casting a recognizable
face he uh he wanted to find some fresh
talent so he put the word out and saw
how many was it uh ten thousand i think
it was over twenty thousand twenty
thousand he saw twenty thousand girls
and long story short he picked you yes
two years ago we were approached by an
anonymous donor who handed over this
huge cache of film and it was footage
from rehearsals behind the scenes b-roll
and completed shots from the shoots
as far as we can tell
this is everything that remains of the
three mrsa marcel movies
before i go i would like some token of
our friendship
[Music]
you could have walked away from this
we brainstormed how best to use this
footage how to make it available to the
world
so first we very carefully cleaned and
scanned all of the film digitizing
everything
but there were enough gaps where we
weren't able to cut full movies
so we took some of the ideas from my
earlier games her story of teleclass the
idea of a more exploratory way of
viewing film stories and we built on
that
we created a virtual movie over a way of
looking through the footage as if you
were back in the editing screen arthur
fisher or john dirk
and to build on this idea we came up
with a new mechanic a kind of visual
concordance
does this work as confession
exploration by match
[Music]
good work
when you're watching at any point you
can stop and point to an image an actor
a prop and the system will create a
match cut to another piece of footage
with that image now it's worth more
so you kind of surf through the footage
in a way following a breadcrumb trail of
visuals
creating your own montage
[Music]
it's both expressive and exploratory
like the best of video games
[Music]
when you have a situation like this
where no one really knows what happened
to marissa marcel
people tend to fill in their blanks
their imagination goes to dark places
i would not use the word haunted
[Music]
do you ever wish you lived in a simpler
safer more optimistic time
trevor hill does
he lives in arcadia a utopian-american
town in the 1970s where the future seems
brighter than ever like the other
citizens of arcadia he is a contestant
on a reality show where viewers are
secretly judging his every move
when trevor learns the truth from a
rogue technician he goes on the run but
how do you escape in a world where
everyone is always watching
in america
now in its 55th season
american arcadia
[Music]
control subject on the run on camera
4025 interrupt broadcast immediately
bienvenidos
[Music]
stop immediately
run keep
no
the hallway to the server room is
tracked by three surveillance cameras i
need to get close to the cameras and
upload the loop footage from my cell
phone
[Music]
yes trust me
oh oh no no no
all the videos are uploaded and playing
the loops i can enter the server room
now
american arcadia references
tentative
[Music]
hey uh
hey i i can't see anything in here oh
geez man just hug your teddy bear real
tight while i try to turn on the lights
okay
okay is that better now let's try to
find a way out of here
trevor are you wheezing you're in
terrible shape man
don't you get any exercise at all
[Music]
no not not since pe in high school
because of my metabolism i
don't easily gain weight so i don't
usually okay i'm not here to judge your
lifestyle or your dietary habits just
save your breath and keep going
in american arcadia what we want to tell
is that you don't need to live just for
getting likes on social networks just do
the things